[Music]
for example toddlers and tiaras was on
television I was watching that show and
then I just decided I'll hit the info
button see what it says and it says tune
in every week as the Department of
Social Services collects more evidence
[Applause]
then I turn the choice watching c-span
watching c-span for a bit watch it for a
while and then I hit the button and it
said what to watch when the non-stop
excitement of the golf channel leaves
you a physical and emotional wreck it
happens yeah scorpion I was watching the
show scorpion launching that for a
little while and then it said I hit the
button a team does missions blah blah
blah but this time it's called scorpion
[Applause]
affair a highly trained team of looking
people
I was watching duck dynasty and then I
hit the button and it said guess which
cast member will be America's new
Secretary of Transportation
I think the guy on the far left one with
the beard beard million dollar listing I
was watching million dollar listing yeah
and then I hit the button it said you'll
never guess how much these houses are
listed for yeah wonder watching Dateline
and then hit the button you weren't
thinking about killing your spouse
before you started watching but you are
now
dr. Phil hit the button magical beaver
takes human form to give short-term
fixes to serious
all right the walking dead yeah walking
dead then I hit the info button sent in
year three of the Trump presidency
[Applause]
you